[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: The poet Roland
Barthes talks about the amorous
embrace as this
post-coital cuddling,
this intersubjective
ecstasy that you enter
with your romantic partner.
And that is beyond sexuality.
That is beyond
physical attraction.
That space of shared
soul-smearing.
Sort of sexually enabled,
technologically mediated,
Buddhist space where
two become one.
I keep bringing back term
intersubjective, ecstasy.
Why do we love to cuddle?
Why do we love to give each
other baby names and treat
each other like
we're little children
and create kind of womb-like
spaces of comfort and divinity
for one another where we can
be as gods outside of time,
temporarily stepping off
that people mover that's
carrying everyone else towards
death, as Alan Harrington says?
We're trying to find
escapes from the despair.
Together we are creating
a shared universe
where we can float above
the clouds of entropy.
Where we cannot die.
That is what love is about.
It's about saving
ourselves from mortality.
We are the gods with anuses,
as Ernest Becker says.
And we do everything we can to
deny our own creaturely-ness,
to deny our own decay,
to deny all you despair.
Can you blame us for squeezing
so tightly around one another?
Can you blame us for wanting
to listen to beautiful music
and cry together?
Can you blame us for
wanting to seek out
comfort in each other's
cold soul space and to say,
please tell me you
will not leave me,
you will not disappear.
I will not be alone.
I'm not going to drown.
Just like, ah.
That's what we want.
That's what we seek.
And they say, oh,
we're co-dependent.
We're weak.
We should be independent.
But come on, man.
It's what all the psychedelic
explorers have told us.
It's eco-delic.
It's all interconnected.
We are all one.
We're not alone.
It's OK to be co-dependent.
It's not a bad thing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]